HE WAS A POST PLAYER IN COLLEGE.
>> I ASKED HIM HOW DOES HE SHOOT
THE THREE, THAT'S HOW I STARTED
TO SHOOT THE NBA THREE.
>> BRING IN REGGIE MILLER, RAY
ALLEN.
REGGIE IS CALLING THE GAME.
RAY, HOW ARE YOU.
>> WHAT'S UP.
>> WE'RE ALL GOOD.
TELL ME WHAT KIND OF NIGHT THIS
IS.
WHAT KIND OF THOUGHTS ARE GOING
THROUGH YOUR MIND.
YOU HAD THE RECORD FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS.
NOW YOU'RE ONE AHEAD OF STEPHEN
CURRY.
>> WELL, I'M HONORED TO BE HERE.
JUST EVERYTHING THAT'S TAKEN
PLACE THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
JUST REMINDED ME OF HOW GRACIOUS
REGGIE WAS AS I WAS GOING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE I WAS HERE FOR
STEPH BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH A
MONUMENTOUS OCCASION.
IT IS AMAZING TO BE HERE.
THE WORLD FAMOUS GARDEN, TO BE
HERE, WATCH THIS HAPPEN, I'M
GLAD TO BE HERE.
>> YOU KNOW, RAY, I SAID EARLIER
WHEN I SAW YOU THREE GUYS
TALKING, I SAID I WOULD WANT
THAT PICTURE, YOU THREE GUYS
STANDING TOGETHER TO PUT ON MY
WALL.
YOU GOT ARGUABLY THREE GREATEST
SHOOTERS THAT EVER LIVED.
YOU GET ANY PICTURES, MAN, THAT
WOULD BE COOL TO GO ON MY WALL.
>> WE GOT A LOT, FOR SURE.
YOU'LL SEE THEM ALL OVER SOCIAL
MEDIA FOR SURE.
>> HEY, SHAQ, TELL YOUR LOVELY
MOTHER I SAID HELLO.
>> WILL DO.
HOW YOU DOING, SHAQ.
>> YOU PARTAKE IN THE
CONVERSATION OF THE BEST SHOOTER
EVER, AND IF YOU DO, WHERE DO
YOU PUT YOURSELF?
>> WELL, I ALWAYS TAKE MYSELF
OUT OF THAT CONVERSATION BECAUSE
I CAN ONLY SEE WHAT I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WATCH GROWING UP AS A
YOUNG PERSON AND DALE ELLIS,
CURRY, REGGIE ARE AT THE TOP OF
MY LIST.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY
AGAINST AND WITH DELL ELLIS AND
AGAINST ALL THREE OF THEM, AND I
AM WHO I AM BECAUSE OF THOSE
THREE PLAYERS.
I WOULD NEVER TRY TO EVEN SAY
THAT I WAS AT THE LEVEL THAT
THEY ARE BECAUSE I THINK ALL
THREE OF THOSE GUYS ARE PART OF
MY DNA.
>> SHOOTING IS VERY SUBJECTIVE.
EVERYONE'S PERSONAL FAVORITE, WE
ALL APPROACHED THIS GAME A
LITTLE DIFFERENT.
I THINK TONIGHT IS ALL ABOUT
STEPHEN.
WE'RE HERE TO GIVE HIM HIS
FLOWERS BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S
ONLY TWO GUYS OBVIOUSLY IN THE
BUILDING TONIGHT THAT KIND OF
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAS GONE INTO
THE MAKING OF BECOMING IN MY
OPINION THE GREATEST SHOOTER OF
ALL TIME, THE HARD WORK, GOING
TO THE GYM WHEN NO ONE ELSE IS
THERE WITH THE KEYS, OPENING IT
UP, TURNING ON THE LIGHTS,
SWEEPING THE FLOOR, AND PUTTING
UP A THOUSAND, 2,000 SHOTS.
THAT'S STEPHEN CURRY, RAY ALLEN,
LARRY BYRD AND A LOT OF THE
OTHER GUYS.
IT IS VERY SUBJECTIVE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE TO KIND OF
CLASS US AND GROUP US ALL
TOGETHER, WE'RE ALL DIFFERENT
AND WE RESPECT ONE ANOTHER.
NOW, IF YOU ASK US IF THERE WAS
A SHOOTING CONTEST OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT ALL IN OUR PRIME, OUR
COMPETITIVE NATURES WILL COME
OUT, BUT TONIGHT'S THE NIGHT FOR
STEPHEN CURRY AND HIS FLOWERS.
>> I HAVE TO SAY, JUST THINKING
ABOUT BEING IN THIS MOMENT AND
EVERYTHING THAT REGGIE SAID, AS
A YOUNG PERSON, I WOULD WALK
INTO ANY ARENA ANYTIME I PLAYED
THE PACERS, YOU COULD WALK DOWN
THE HALLWAY, GET A GLIMPSE OF
THE COURT, EVERY TIME I WAS
THERE, REGGIE WAS SHOOTING.
THAT WAS HUGE.
TO KNOW WHAT THE GREATS DO.
IT SET ME IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AS A YOUNG PLAYER.
I THINK THAT WHILE WE HAVE THIS
MOMENT, WHILE WE'RE PLAYING IN
THIS GAME, WE HAVE TO DO WHAT WE
CAN.
ONCE WE'RE GONE, NOW THE YOUNG